laurent alexandre bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes chirurgien chef d'entreprise
confondateur de doctissimo aujourd'hui à
la tête d'une société de séquençage adn
et vous êtes un spécialiste de nouvelles
technologies de l'intelligence
artificielle à laquelle vous consacrer
ce dernier livre la guerre des
intelligences et tout d'abord cette
question évidente très simple qu'est ce
que l'intelligence artificielle
à partir de quand peut-on parler
d'intelligence artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle c'est un
système qui réalise mieux que l'homme
des tâches ces intellectuels qui était
réservé au cerveau biologique des
humains jusqu'à maintenant et cette
intelligence artificielle déjà présent
dans le monde qui nous entoure
dans quels exemples concrets par exemple
les voitures autonome les applications
qui lie à sur nos téléphones portables
sont déjà le fruit d'intelligence
artificielle
ce sont des intelligences artificielles
qui n'ont qui ne fonctionne pas comme
l'intelligence humaine
elles n'ont pas conscience d'elle-même
elles ne savent pas ce qu'elles font
mais elles sont capables de conduire
mieux que nous des voitures autonomes
elles sont capables de faire un
diagnostic cancérologique dans certains
domaines
mieux que les meilleurs cancérologue
monde et oui un set que vous nous
expliquer dans votre livre nous sommes
au début d'une révolution d'un
changement de civilisation avec ses
risques et ses promesses et du côté des
promesses on vous venez d'en parler un
elia et bientôt toutes ses promesses
médicale dans votre livre vous parlez
bien des des cancers de la peau de
l'orthodontie vous parler de beaucoup de
promesses médical ainsi de suite oui oui
il ya plein de demain où l'intelligence
artificielle progresse et elle va nous
permettre de réaliser des choses
incroyables pour mesurer la vitesse à
laquelle elle progresse le meilleur
exemple c'est de voir ce qui s'est passé
sur le jeu de go le logiciel développé
par google
alpha go a été bête qui avait battu le
champion du monde du jeu de go a lui
même été battus par la nouvelle version
de google par 100 parties à zéro c'est à
dire la toute dernière version de google
au bout de quatre mois de
redéveloppement a gagné par 100 à 0
contre la version qui avait terrassé le
champion du monde on voit que
l'intelligence artificielle galope et
que les intelligences artificielles
arrive à battre des intelligences
artificielles qui bat l'homme
on est dans une course d intelligence
artificielle
elle vers toujours plus de puissance il
ya d'ailleurs une spécificité au jeu de
go vous l'expliquais dans votre livre ce
n'est pas du tout la même chose que les
échecs qui a un jeu vraiment
mathématiques dans le jeu de go il ya de
l'intuition
oui tout à fait et d'ailleurs le
champion du monde du jeu de go qui ji a
avoué après avoir été écrabouillé par
par google que ça avait été une
expérience quasi métaphysique pour lui
qu'il avait été bouleversé qu'il avait
compris le jeu de go sous un jour
totalement différent et que le logiciel
de google lui avait permis de comprendre
un niveau de complexité qu'il
n'imaginait pas possible on voit que
même une intelligence artificielle qui
n'a pas conscience d'elle-même est
capable de nous bouleverser est capable
de création est capable d'inventer des
choses et à une vitesse qui défie
l'entendement parce que les hommes ont
mis trois mille ans pour progresser au
jeu de go et la nouvelle version d'alpha
go a été construite en quelques jours il
a ouvre des perspectives
incroyable très inattendu par exemple si
on reste sur le domaine de la santé
les géants du numérique à les gaffes a
comme on dit travail aujourd'hui et bien
pour microsoft à l'éradication du cancer
facebook ne nous le raconter vous à
l'éradication de toutes les maladies
humaines horizon 2100 oui tout à fait
ben la santé c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
données 1 le séquençage adn d'une tumeur
par exemple ces vingt mille milliards
d'informations pour pour chaque malade
donc il ya des montagnes de données qui
sont créées aujourd'hui dans le dossier
médical de chaque malade et les géants
du numérique américain google apple
facebook amazon et puis les chinois
baidu et alibaba ten shades yaoumi sont
tous en train de rentrer dans la santé
et ils vont devenir probablement des
acteurs majeurs dans les vingt ou trente
années qui viennent 2 du monde de
l'éducation et du monde de la santé
c'est un challenge énorme pour nos
hôpitaux pour les médecins et pour les
professeurs il y à risque si nous ne
faisons pas attention que nous ayons
demain deux grandes sidérurgie la santé
et l'éducation
avec l'arrivée des joueurs du numérique
qui sont avec leur intelligence
artificielle bien plus performant que
nos bureaucratie même si elles font des
choses très bien par ailleurs
effectivement c'est un problème
géopolitique dans tout cela
l'europe est très mal placé par rapport
à la chine et par rapport aux états unis
à l'asticot la silicon valley pourquoi
alors l'europe a raté le coche elle n'a
pas vu arriver l'intelligence
artificielle
comme elle n'a pas vu arriver les
téléphones les smartphones et les
téléphones portables intelligents
l'europe était leader il y a dix ans il
y a dix ans juste sortait l'iphone 1 et
apple n'existait pas dans le monde du
téléphone portable google n'était pas
encore rentrées nettes n'avait pas créé
android nokia un européen avait 55 % du
marché mondial du téléphone portable
nokia est mort 100 % des téléphones
portables sur terre fonctionne soit soit
paul soit sous google android
l'europe a été écrabouillé la chine son
sort elle est là des géants du numérique
aujourd'hui 1
l'éditeur de huy chat qui s'appelle
tencent et la dixième plus grosses
entreprises au monde en terme en termes
de valeur mais l'europe n'a rien elle
n'a que des crapauds numérique face au
géant chinois et américains mais vous
êtes très inquiet pour l'europe et vous
êtes très sévère à l'école à l'égard des
politiques dans votre livre des
politiques qui pour vous sont des
analphabètes de la technologie alors il
y en a un seul que vous sauvez c'est
emmanuel macron tout de même qui pour
vous et technophile et pâques emmanuel
macron olivier ferrand
monsieur blanc caire mounir majidi etc
sont des gens sur des gens qui ont une
bonne culture numérique est donc en
marche tout de même je suivrai que c'est
là qu'elle est le nous sommes gens qui
connaissent l'intelligence est filmé il
ya aussi des gens qui sont pas mauvais
quelqu'un qui n'a pas beaucoup la cote
en ce moment comme comme jean françois
copé est un très bon connaisseur de
l'intelligence artificielle xavier
bertrand également
dr il ya un réveil des politiques mais
maintenant il faut qu on galope parce
que comme on a perdu la première hier on
le voit bien avec les joueurs du
numérique et qu'on est mal barré en
termes d'intelligence artificielle on
risque vraiment d'être déclassé sur le
plan industriel et technologique
si on ne se réveille pas très vite et
puis on a une deuxième bataille à mener
c'est la bataille de l'école c'est que
l'école aujourd'hui n'a pas réalisé que
l'intelligence artificielle arrive et
l'école de 2017 est en train de former
nos enfants à des métiers où ils vont
être laminée écrabouillé par
l'intelligence artificielle
il faut changer radicalement le
management à l'éducation nationale il
faut que l'éducation nationale intègre
des spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle pour comprendre comment et
surtout vers où il faut envoyer nos
enfants dans les années qui viennent
parce que les enfants qui sont rentrés
en maternelle le mois dernier en
septembre 2017 ils seront encore sur le
marché du travail en 2070 et je peux
vous promettre que l'éducation nationale
de 2017 ne forme pas nos enfants et nos
petits enfants à être compétitif
vis-à-vis de l'intelligence artificielle
en 2070 mais là vous dédié à votre livre
à mounir mahjoubi et à jean michel
blanquer rend le ministre de l'intérieur
biologique un dites vous donc vous le
dites si l'école ne prépare pas les
enfants d'aujourd'hui à la révolution de
demain
eh bien ils seront inemployables à ce
que pour vous l'avènement de
l'intelligence artificielle est synonyme
est bien de fin du travail pour certains
de fin du travail tel qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui le débat est ouvert
aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui il y aura pas de fin
du travail parce que l'aventuré humaine
ne fait que commencer vous avez
probablement vu les projets d'elon musk
de le fondateur d automobile tesla le
projet jeff bezos ce le propriétaire
d'amazon de conquérir le cosmos et il
estime qu'il faut des milliers de
milliards d'hommes pour développer les
projets spatiaux dans la galaxie
l'aventuré humaine ne fait que commencer
donc le travail ne mourra jamais en
revanche ce qui n'est pas sûr du tout
c'est que nous ayons le temps de former
les gens qui aujourd'hui vont être
dépassés par l'intelligence artificielle
pour aller vers des nouveaux métiers et
comme l'école a pris énormément de
retard
il ya le grand risque qu'on arrive à ce
que décrit le philosophe israélien ari
dans homo des us c'est à dire des dieux
qu'ils maîtrisent intelligence
artificielle et des inutiles qu'il
appelle les useless en anglais et qui
seraient abandonnées par le système
parce que incapable d'être compétitif
face à l'intelligence artificielle il
faut vraiment que l'école se modernise
très vite
aujourd'hui l'école est un monstre
bureaucratique avec des querelles
syndicales
c'est pas le sujet du moment c'est pas
de se battre entre syndicats à rue de
grenelle qui compte c'est de sauver
l'avenir de nos enfants modernisant
l'école et on les rendre compétitifs
face à l'intelligence artificielle et ça
suppose un changement complet de
gouvernance de l'éducation
quel regard portez-vous sur le revenu
universel
on sait notamment au niveau et bien des
gars fin et sans parler du débat qu'il y
avait ici en france notamment a soulevé
par benoît hamon en tout cas les géants
du numérique américains sont favorables
à un revenu universel temporaire un
tampon pour permettre à bien aux
personnes qui ne sont pas adaptés qui
pourrais je suis favorable bien sûr à
une indemnisation du chômage et à une
formation tout au long de la vie pour
que les gens puissent s'adapter aux
chocs technologiques en tant que médecin
en tant que spécialiste du cerveau je
pense que ce serait une monstrueuse
connerie de développer le revenu
universel permanent pour une raison très
simple c'est que le cerveau ça profite
quand il ne travaille pas et qu' on a vu
par exemple chez les chauffeurs de taxi
londoniens quand wen est arrivé et a le
moins sexy
ils ont cessé de retenir le plan de
londres eh bien on voit au scanner et
l'irm un effondrement de la taille de
l'hippocampe qui est la zone chargée de
la mémoire dans le cerveau
si nous travaillons moins on va âtre au
pied le cerveau des gens qui ont déjà
des difficultés à être compétitif face à
l'intelligence artificielle je pense que
c'est une vraie fausse idée je pense que
tu as siège pollue un piège politique ce
serait une monstrueuse âneries de
développer le revenu universel on aurait
simplement des publics de
plus en plus fragile et de plus en plus
incapables de rentrer sur le marché du
travail parce qu'ils auraient de réelles
atrophie du cerveau il faut au contraire
réformer le système de formation
éduquer les gens les rendre compétitifs
face à l'intelligence artificielle il
faut développer le cerveau est pas
mettre les gens au rebut ou revenu
universel
merci beaucoup laurent alexandre d'avoir
répondu à mes questions dont je rappelle
le titre de votre livre la guerre des
intelligences un livre assez vertigineux
sur l'intelligence artificielle merci